this plume of smoke is rising from a
town
in syria a similar scene
unfolded in another town about a hundred
kilometers away these attacks were the
result of turkish air strikes
on october 9 2019 when turkey's invasion
of northern syria began
the long-planned turkish military
operation in northeast syria
has been launched turkey pushing ever
deeper into syria
at least 160 000 civilians are believed
to have fled the fighting in the border
area
over the next several days the turkish
military moved further into syria and
attacked several
other towns all of these attacks are
concentrated here on this strip of land
in northeast syria
it's part of an area that turkey has
been wanting to turn into a so-called
safe zone for years
so what is this safe zone and what
purpose does it really serve
for turkey
[Music]
syria descended into armed conflict in
2011.
[Applause]
protests broke out against the country's
authoritarian government
in major cities when the government
turned its attention to the uprisings
and violently cracked down it left a
power vacuum in the north
that's where the jihadist militant group
isis swept in
starting in 2013.
[Music]
significant portions of this region
which was home to syria's largest ethnic
minority group called the kurds
were eventually conquered by isis
but kurdish militias successfully fought
back
so the u.s backed them with air support
and on-the-ground training against isis
in 2015 kurdish and non-kurdish militias
in the region
banded together to form the syrian
democratic forces
or sdf and started pushing isis back
this paved the way for the expansion of
a kurdish-led territory which was
already being established here
by 2019 the sdf effectively broke the
isis stronghold in the north
they set up prisons that held around 11
000
captive isis fighters and housed tens of
thousands of isis family members
in displacement camps
u.s military bases also cropped up in
this kurdish-run
area and u.s troops began patrolling the
syrian turkish border
[Music]
across the border in turkey president
recep tayyip erdogan has long viewed the
rise of the kurds in syria
as a threat that's because a kurdish
separatist group in turkey called the
pkk
has fought the turkish government for
decades
the pkk has pushed for greater autonomy
for kurds living in turkey
but the turkish government has rejected
their autonomy and fought back
the violent conflict between the two has
left tens of thousands dead
erdogan claims the pkk is aligned with
kurdish forces
in syria and he sees their growing
influence across the border as
a risk a kurdish-governed territory in
syria could inspire kurds in turkey to
import the same model
back home
erdogan has launched attacks on kurds in
syria multiple times
the first came in 2016 when turkish
troops attacked here in the northwest
to push back isis and block kurdish
expansion
along the border and in 2018
they attacked syria again this time in
an attempt to wipe out the sdf
[Music]
turkey gained control over these areas
but
by this time it was facing problems
within its borders
a trade war with the us and economic
mismanagement by the country's leaders
had caused turkey's economy to crash
and many found themselves unable to find
work as unemployment increased
this economic downturn caused many in
turkey to look for
a scapegoat in syrian refugees
the war in syria forced over 6 million
to flee the country
and 3.6 million of those refugees fled
to
turkey more than any other nation
as turkey's economy slumped more and
more turks disapproved of president
erdogan
and resented the influx of refugees
in 2014 erdogan's justice and
development party
had broad support it won 50 mayoral
seats
more than half the country's local
leadership but in march 2019 his
party lost 11 of those seats in local
elections
to make matters worse a pro-kurdish
party the people's democratic party
won eight mayoral seats and helped other
opposition candidates win across the
country
voters delivered the turkish president
his worst night ever at the ballot box
this is all reflecting some major
discomfort with the president the kurds
have become the key in this result
to regain political popularity the
pressure was on erdogan to
act
[Music]
after the elections he doubled down on
an idea he had been proposing for years
a safe zone between turkey and syria
erdogan had already taken control of
this region
in northwest syria now he wanted to
expand that territory to the east
further into kurdish-led land
erdogan claimed that the purpose of this
safe zone would be to move syrian
refugees
back into this strip of syria he took
this plan to russia
and the us but he couldn't get them on
board
with political pressure mounting at home
erdogan and his government
threatened to move into syria on their
own arsenals
but there was an obstacle in their way
the us an ally to turkey
and a military supporter of the kurds
still had troops stationed in northern
syria
so turkey couldn't make its move in
august 2019
turkey made some progress with the u.s
the two agreed to a safe zone that they
would patrol together
this zone would extend five kilometers
into northern syria
the sdf cooperated by withdrawing some
of their forces
but this agreement wasn't enough for
erdogan
at the u.n a month later he proposed a
much
larger zone we intend to establish
a peace corridor with a depth of 30
kilometers
and the length of 480 kilometers
in syria and enabled the settlement of
two million
syrians there soon after this address
turkey found a way into syria after a
phone call with erdogan
president donald trump ordered the
withdrawal of u.s troops from northern
syria
it's now time to bring our soldiers home
i don't want to
leave troops there it's very dangerous
fair we never agreed to
protect the kurds for the rest of their
lives trump broke the u.s alliance with
the kurds
and pulled troops from along the border
erdogan finally seized his opportunity
and sent troops into northeastern syria
[Music]
turkey's invasion has been brutal and
destabilizing
what's happening in syria can only be
described as chaos
kurdish hospitals have been overwhelmed
thousands are still on the move
trying to escape this violence families
desperate to get
out of here turkey is sending in arab
militias
that would displace the kurds from their
homes as the sdf defends itself against
turkish forces
they're leaving isis prisons unguarded
and
according to kurdish sources hundreds
have already escaped
the us withdrawal and turkey's invasion
have created a
new power vacuum in northern syria one
that's quickly being filled
as the u.s leaves another force draws in
the kurds have made a deal with syria's
president turkey's president and russian
president vladimir putin
making a deal about the future of syria
withdrawal of u.s troops is leading to
more
change than the area has seen in years
you